Vernon Vernon Brown used to be a country
music star not on this
now he's just a parolee and Elvis
impersonator young man and a fake
preacher but he just found out he's one
more thing
you get visitation rights say what for
your 15 year old daughter Rucker off for
one wild
ride text me if you need anything no I
can't get you out of it this Sunday in
the town
the man's got to do with any red-blooded
American man does when he's on his own
drink beer and what's real like probably
pray what was that for same thing you
said
you gotta go big and I'll be big big
please seek massage is unusually
centralized welcome how could I ever
trust you again just ball front door
that does just be way more romantic a
blessed morning to you faster I'm just
gonna wait right here
CMT it's a new come you can't say no to
everything that's come from Billy Ray
Cyrus luck feedings mythological bird
with city hot dirty and old women love
he's doing all the wrong things I'm out
let's know a little bit about how you
guys met for all the right reasons
it's called cake Jam it's this any music
fest do even one yeah I mean whatever
still the king hey wait a minute you
didn't check the list for those two hot
chicks world premiere Sunday 9:00 8:00
central
on CMT